القرارات كلها كانت تصبه في صلاح الثوره
ده كان مطلبنا فعلا من الاول انا في رايي
انها تؤسس الاستبداد يعني قرارات جيده
وانا بشوف انها هي بتساعد مع الثوره لا
افكر انه يتجر يستعمل المواد الكيمياويه
ضد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
شعبه
نظام بشار الاسد نحنا دائما عننا والجيش
جيش الاسد دائما عم يعتمد يلعب باوراق و
ويكون بصراعات ثانيه يعني مثل ما شفنا اخر
شي اللي حصل مخيم يرموك حاول يزج
الفلسطينيين ويدخلهم
بالصراع عم ددور في سوريا اللي هو بين
الثوار على الارض وبين كتائب الاسد في
البدايه اكيد نقمه النظام السي هي على عدم
مشاركه حركه حماس والجهاد الاسلامي في
الحرب مع الجيش السوري اشتدت نقمه نظم
كثيرا على الفلسطينيين ولكن الموقع
الاساسي لمخيم اليرموك والذي يقع بين مطار
دمشق الدولي اعتقد و مدينه دمشق لذلك هو
منطقه استراتيجيه هامه جدا لسقوط العاصمه
اعتقد ان ما يحدث في مخيم اليرموك ب سوريا
هو نسخه لما حدث ل فلسطينيين في لبنان ب
الحرب الاهليه بين الاشقاء اللبنانيين
لذلك نعتقد ان ما يحدث في المخيم لابد من
تطويقه في الاجال القريبه للحلول دون زج
الفلسطينيين في الصراع الداخلي السوري
والله انا اعتقد انه هناك في ناس مشبوه
تقوم على اطاره الفتنه والفوضى من اجل زج
الفلسطينيين في هذا الصراع
و ونحن في ونحن في فلسطين يعني نطالب بان
لا يكون للفلسطينيين اي دور في هذا الصراع
ونطالب احمد جبريل رئيس القياده العامه
للجبهه
الشعبيه بتحمل مسؤولياته الكامله وعدم زج
اي فلسطيني بهذا الصراع لاننا نحن ضيوف في
سوريا وليست لنا علاقه بما
يجري
[موسيقى]
ا